[Music]
what a ponce de leon alexander the great
and jason jiami all have in common
superstitions what are superstitions why
do we even believe them although there
are a lot of weird superstitions out
there there may be psychological
benefits to believing them let's find
out why
[Music]
about 25 percent of people consider
themselves superstitious but it's
probably more than that do you say bless
you after someone sneezes why well it's
polite but how did this become a thing
some say this tradition dates back to
the ancient romans who thought that when
you sneezed your soul was ejected from
the body and a blessing was the only way
to protect it from being stolen by the
devil another theory is that pope
gregory who became pope after his
predecessor died from the plague would
say god bless you whenever someone
sneezed as a way of wishing them good
health another theory is that some
believed your heart would stop beating
for a brief moment during a sneeze and a
blessing encouraged the heart to start
beating again
you good
i didn't get it don't you hate that yeah
it's untight thank you
superstitions are all around us next
time you're in a tall building check out
the elevator eighty percent of high-rise
buildings in the u.s don't have a 13th
floor lufthansa and air france don't
have a 13th row fear of the number 13 is
called triscodecophobia but that's
mostly in the west in much of the east
and southeast asia you'll find
tetraphobia fear of the number four in
the chinese language and its subgroups
the word for and the word die are
pronounced almost the same
thank you so superstitions are universal
we've all had those days where from the
moment we wake up we're grumpy annoyed
at the whole world and everything seems
against us we call this waking up on the
wrong side of the bed this is another
one that comes from ancient rome romans
like to wake up on the right side of the
bed
literally they believed that all things
on the left side were evil or sinister
in fact the word sinister comes from the
latin word sinistra so waking up on the
left side of the bed was literally a
sign of sinister things to come and if
you're having a bad day you can always
say tomorrow will be better then you say
knock on wood the superstition to knock
on wood appears to date back to the 19th
century some believe it has beginnings
in religion with the crucifix others say
that trees were seen as harbingers of
good luck and knocking on them chased
demons away yet another claim is that
the expression comes from an old
children's game from the uk called tiggy
touchwood which is essentially a game
attack
now what touchwood
don't be an infant
[Music]
millions of people practice
superstitions every day and probably
don't know why or where the need to do
so comes from so why do some of us
believe in seemingly irrational
superstitions turns out there's actually
psychology at work here the short answer
is it's a coping mechanism for anxiety
the world is a crazy unpredictable place
it's only natural that we want to have
as much control of the unpredictable as
possible and for some people these
beliefs could be effective a study
reported by the association for
psychological science showed that people
who cross their fingers for luck had an
increase in manual dexterity and even an
improvement in memory function the study
concluded that crossing one's fingers
increased self-confidence enough so that
some people's golf scores improved hey
maybe crossing your fingers will help us
with the youtube algorithm
oh i know what we could try what throw a
coin in the fountain right throwing
coins and fountains also goes back to
ancient times when community wells were
built in villages coins were often
thrown in as offerings to the gods
there's a well in north umberland
england where people would pray to the
goddess of wells and springs coventina
sixteen thousand coins from different
eras of the roman empire were found
there
but we don't have a fountain hello i
believe in one
okay
let's try it
[Music]
anything
i don't think so try again
nothing
again
wait a minute
as you can see
people will easily part with their
hard-earned money if they think a
superstition can benefit them somehow
some televangelist organizations will
send you spiritually charged holy water
which promises to solve your financial
woes for a small donation
yep
[Music]
tales about water and its ability to
magically heal have been around for
thousands of years alexander the great
believed in a river that cured old age
he was only 32 when he was poisoned to
death so who knows if he was right
legend says ponce de leon accidentally
discovered florida when he was searching
for the fountain of youth now most
historians think that's an exaggeration
but 500 years later the legend endures
these supernatural myths provide a sense
of hope in the cases of alexander and
ponce leon they cooled the anxiety of
aging psychologically belief in
superstition is like watching stage
magic and illusionists willingly we set
aside rational thought and engage with
the impossible and spectacular we will
believe a person has been cut in half
and put back together or that an
illusionist was able to teleport from
one place to another now we know penn
and teller's bullet catch in the teeth
is staged but wow is it a great trick
[Music]
you recognize that bullet quest yes i do
seven when you signed yes it was
although they never give the secret to
the trick away they stress there's
nothing supernatural in their stunts
it's just entertainment pen gillette
summed it up by saying we are
professional liars just honest liars but
what happens when less ethical
illusionists use similar stage magic to
cash in on the grieving through
spiritualism such as seances these
mediums use all sorts of tricks to make
objects appear to hover in the dark and
other phony illusions in an attempt to
give themselves credibility even famous
magician and escape artist houdini
himself made it a mission to expose
these frauds houdini took it so
seriously that he campaigned against
this fake spiritualism in front of
congress this thing they call
spiritualism we're in a medium
intercommunicates with the dead is a
fraud from start to finish superstition
is found everywhere in society and
there's no place that's more prevalent
than in professional sports baseball is
known for cheering crowds hot dogs and
steroids well yes that too players and
managers are notoriously superstitious
if players are on a streak they don't
wash their caps some wear mismatched
socks in order to break a slump jason
giambi would wear a gold thong i don't
know if he always got a hit but he
always felt sexy
nobody had more extreme superstitions
than relief pitcher turk wendell he made
sure to never touch the foul lines he
would actually jump over them and each
time he took the mound he had to have
four pieces of black licorice in his
mouth and after each inning he brushed
his teeth sounds like ocd it does but
psychologists don't see them as
connected and people with ocd can't not
do the rituals they do or it causes them
great pain and anxiety that's why it's
called a compulsion superstition on the
other hand as long as it's not taken to
the extreme is not considered a problem
your mind is a powerful tool and if
crossing your fingers improves your
memory do it if writing a symbol in the
dirt improves your golf game do it
you're probably not channeling a
supernatural force but you are actively
and mindfully forcing yourself to focus
to be present to quell your anxiety and
controlling anxiety is healthy so by all
means throw salt over your shoulder
knock on wood and say bless you when
somebody sneezes you may not be saving
their soul but psychologically speaking
you might be in some small part
saving your own
[Music]
thank you so much for hanging out with
us today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor
subscribe comment like share all that
stuff really helps the channel and cross
your fingers that we can defeat the
algorithm hey every little bit helps it
really does and special thanks to
patrons jim h daniel mauricio ew grant
stella dalton sal and everyone who makes
this channel possible if you'd like to
support this channel there's a link to
patreon in the description until next
time be safe be kind and know that you
are appreciated
you